leur dernière rencontre remonte à
février 2023 le Premier ministre
polonais s'était rendu à Kiev un an
après le début de l'invasion en Ukraine
l'occasion de rappeler les liens
historiques qui lilitent deux pays le
déplacement avoir suivi du président
ukrainien ne durera que quelques heures
avec un agenda très chargé rappelle les
champs céleri heureusement
sur la situation sécuritaire sur ce qui
se passe sur le front sur la façon dont
la communauté internationale devrait
réagir à cette agression russe
[Musique]
couvre également des questions
importantes pour la Pologne
Varsovie est l'un des plus fervents
soutiens de Kiev depuis le début de la
guerre soutien économique mais aussi
militaire il y a deux jours la Pologne a
livré plusieurs chasseurs Mig29 alors
que d'autres alliés comme la France à la
Grande-Bretagne hésitent encore à
franchir le pas dans les rues de
Varsovie la venue du président ukrainien
est vue d'un bon œil
il s'agit sans aucun doute d'une visite
qui aura une certaine importance pour la
poursuite de la coopération entre la
Pologne et l'Ukraine j'espère qu'une
fois la guerre terminée nous serons
prioritaires pour obtenir des accords
permettant la reconstruction du pays
nous avons gagné en marge de sa visite
volody mirzen ski doit aller à la
rencontre de la population
ukrainienne qui a fui la guerre pour se
réfugier en Pologne depuis le début de
l'invasion le pays a accueilli plus d'un
million et demi